I was gonna talk to John Iong about what
is he doing during Corona oh there he is
hey John
how much TV by the way are you watching
because you used to watch it an
inordinate amount of TV before all this
went down
are you like wall-to-wall TV now Howard
I haven't moved from this couch it's
been fantastic yeah you know like 600
pal light they to cut the person out of
the couch that's me on do you get up to
[ __ ] or do you just do it right in the
couch good we had a total if they made a
total leather couch I would buy it I
would be great John created a guide for
what to watch on TV while everyone is
staying at home and we posted it on
Howard Stern comm a lot of the guys in
the office were saying that John's list
is exactly what you'd expect from a
middle-aged middle-class white guy like
he left out a lot of shows that like
power-on stars or watched it yeah Robin
recommended power to me and I was like
oh what's that yes it is a white
middle-class guy list but the TV on
there I put up is incredible Robin do
you want to hear John's list let me have
it
Breaking Bad which we've seen of course
but wire which I've seen which is
fantastic Howard let me interrupt you
you can re-watch if you Breaking Bad is
excellent as a real watch to because you
don't have to wait a week for all the
episodes and it fly I mean it's it's
really really good of a second time
around I'd end up breaking bed I love
that show but it makes me uncomfortable
like I get to to crazy from it yeah you
get more crazy watching it binging it
yeah The Sopranos which I recommend to
I've watched each episode 50 times so
great great where you watch the show
that you recommend here that I never can
get into it I tried it's Mad Men oh that
man is great that surprises me Howard
because it's advertising it captures
that time period really really well
Jackson you know manipulations going on
you would love it yeah
John recommends Game of Thrones I don't
think I could sit through that [ __ ]
again it's good again
yeah lost forget about I I'm so lost
gets better in like the third and fourth
season yeah it does it does we we it's
just like Game of Thrones he couldn't
criticize it all right how about this
watch just watch the pilot of loss
because it's one of the best pilot you
ever saw agree with you it was it was
really good season yeah then watch
through the first season and then move
on to something else
finishing out the list was sherlock
better call Saul Curb Your Enthusiasm
Fargo shits Creek better things and
killing eat everything with shits Creek
Robin it's great great shows awesome
it's really good it's got you Julian
Catherine O'Hara from sdtv orphan yeah I
like her so that's good although I would
like to make a recommendation for watch
a TV show mr. Edie but if John could
explain to me why did Ed not talk to
anybody but Wilbur
yes actually that's actually a great
question with mr. ed the talking horse
but if you want to laugh watch the
episode where mr. ed tries out for the
Los Angeles Dodgers insides in the hole
you